- Yeah, so we got a tip from a friend
that there is vaccines here
in the (speaking foreign language)
and they're vaccinating people under 50.
So we thought to give it a try.
- [Dov Lieber] These young
and middle-aged people
don't have an appointment but
they've come to this clinic
in Tel Aviv hoping to get
vaccinated against COVID-19.
- I was really nervous to get vaccinated.
And we got it.
- While in most countries
around the world,
you have to be part of a
priority group to be vaccinated.
Israeli clinics have been
giving out any remaining doses
to the general public after
the day scheduled appointments
end for priority patients.
This strategy is one of the
reasons Israel vaccinated
a greater share of its population
than any of the country.
More than 20% in just a few weeks,
way ahead of the U.S.
and European countries
that also have much larger populations.
The country hopes to immunize a majority
of its population by early spring.
- Right now what we see is a race.
On one hand, we have the virus spread
spiraling out of control.
On the other hand, we have
the vaccination campaign
going very quickly.
- [Dov Lieber] Weeks
after the program started
demand was so high, some
clinics had no extra doses left
at the end of the day and
sometimes turned people away.
(speaking foreign language)
- It's always good to try your chances.
And that's why I hopeful.
But sometimes you get unlucky
but there's always a tomorrow.
- [Dov Lieber] We wanted to know
how does Israel's program work exactly.
(speaking foreign language)
Netanyahu announced that
Israel had secured enough doses
of the Pfizer BioNTech shot
to vaccinate everyone over 16
by the end of March.
Although this max vaccination
campaign alone is unlikely
to eradicate the virus, this
timeline sets Israel apart
as other Western nations
have fallen behind schedule.
In the U.S. the vaccination of the elderly
and essential workers alone
is expected to take several more weeks.
One reason Israel has been
able to vaccinate so much
of his population so quickly,
is that it's a relatively
small country with a population
similar to that of New York city.
Israel has transformed
stadiums and other venues
into mass vaccination centers.
Israel also has a technologically advanced
universal healthcare system in
which everyone in the country
is legally required to be
registered unlike the U.S.
where there's a patrick of
public and private coverage.
Israel's digitized system has
helped streamline the process
for those who have an
appointment, including high risk
and priority patients over 60.
- Every member set an
appointment in advance
and it's already scheduled
for two appointments.
For the first dose and the
second dose 21 days later.
Now he comes here in
the exact time and hour
that we asked him to
come, he uses his card
and pulls out a number and
then someone will take him
to one of the stations.
And in the station, the nurse
will document everything.
His name, his ID and the
number of the bottle.
And even in which of the arms
he is going to get the vaccination.
And then she will do the
vaccination and he will wait
for about 15 minutes at the
other side of this compound.
- At the start of the
vaccination campaign,
Israel's program ran into big
issues and many vaccine vials
had to be thrown away.
Israel bought 8 million doses from Pfizer,
paying a premium for early shipments.
As well as 6 million vaccines for Moderna
and 10 million from AstraZeneca.
When the Pfizer vaccine
first arrived in Israel,
hundreds of doses had to be dumped
due to lower than expected turnout.
That's because the BioNTech Pfizer vaccine
must be administered within five days
after leaving the main storage facility
where it must be kept at
ultra cold temperatures
as low as minus 112 degrees Fahrenheit.
After the vaccine dump,
authorities began dividing some
vaccine packages into
smaller shipments for more
isolated areas making for
more efficient distribution.
Professor Balicer is the
Chief Innovation Officer
for Clarit, Israel's those
largest healthcare organization.
And he's helped advise
the Israeli government
on his vaccine strategy.
- We have given the full
permission to every delivery point.
Once they get to the point
in which the tray of vials
is about to become need
for the destruction
because of the time limits and
the cold chain requirements,
they are not only allowed,
we want them to go ahead,
find anyone, bring them in
and put a shot in the arm.
So no vaccine would go to waste.
- [Dov Lieber] The vaccines
are now in high demand
and thanks to the latest
shipment of vaccines,
the country set to start
opening up new appointments
to even more people.
- I think one of the key
challenges we have right now
is we have no means to get
vaccines to the houses of people
who are bedridden and
cannot leave their home.
What we've tried to do
until now was to vaccinate
their key caregivers.
- [Dov Lieber] The
vaccination program comes
at a critical time for
Israel, which early in 2021
had one of the world's
highest infection rates
and fatalities were on the rise
as it entered a third lockdown.
There's also the challenge
of vaccine acceptance
with ongoing skepticism over the shots
and government initiatives in
some parts of the population.
Still here in Tel Aviv,
many people have shown up
hoping to get vaccinated
as soon as possible.
- I came here tonight to
try and to get the vaccine
for the COVID.
And I want to travel, see
world and starting my life
like I wanted to and not
to stay out in quarantine
in my house.
(soft upbeat music)